ANDREW RINGLER: It's like
a file sharing system,
like Dropbox, except you
manually take care of the files
yourself and you worry
about merge conflicts.
So if in Dropbox, you
and your collaborator
added a document at the same
time, it tries to save both
and it goes, aah,
something's wrong.
And it makes one that
says "conflicted copy."
And GitHub does a similar
thing but then it hands it back
to you and it
says, I'm not going
to save that
conflicted copy, you
need to tell me what to do to
resolve that so that I only
have one version of each file
and it's the master version.
So GitHub, in a
nutshell, is just
a way to share files
with other people
collaboratively without
overwriting other people's
stuff and without having
conflicts happen inside
of the cloud where you're
able to share this document.
So what I'm going
to go over today
is GitHub and then briefly how
to add pages and upload them.
So what is GitHub?
Does anyone want to
explain what GitHub is?
Or Git?
The wild guess.
OK.
GitHub is a few things.
GitHub is a web-based platform,
a website for sharing code,
sharing software code--
the source code of software.
So it's created for developers
to collaborate on code.
A lot of code on there
is open source code--
code that the source code is
freely available to look at.
So basically, it's
a website where
you can navigate
other people's code,
you can collaborate
on the same project.
And you can also just look
at other people's projects
so you can submit bug
reports to projects.
So GitHub is the
sort of community.
The other thing it is is
it's a piece of software
based on a technology
called Git,
G-I-T. Git is a piece
of software that
lets you collaborate, basically
lets you share source code.
And GitHub kind of extends
that by making a pretty website
and a few other things.
So Git is a piece of software
called version control.
Has anyone heard
that term before?
Yes?
Does anyone want to explain
that term-- version control?
It is a very fancy way of
saying keeping a history
and storing multiple
versions of things.
So for example,
say, you are working
on some sort of document--
maybe a really important essay.
So this is my really
important essay.
"My essay on bugs by Andrew."
So you're working on this
essay, you save the essay.
Then you make some
changes, you save it again.
And then you're like, oh,
what was the first version
of the essay I did?
It looks so different now.
So one of the
things you'll do is
once you have a
version you like,
maybe you'll take that version
and let's make a copy of it.
Let's call it like v1--
version 1.
Now let's start
working on version 2.
So if we mess something up, we
still have the first version.
And then it's
getting really good.
So then at this point,
we save our version 2.
Let's call this one Final.
So as you work on multiple
versions of the document,
you want to save different
versions in case you mess up.
You might have done that
with an essay before.
You might submit an
essay to professor.
They give you back
a different version
with corrected changes--
an annotated version.
So version control in
software is just a fancy way
of saying the same thing--
it's making multiple
versions of things
that you can go
back to and look at.
The thing with Git, though,
is you don't actually
have to do what I just did.
It does all that
automatically for you.
And that's similar to--
has anyone heard of Time
Machine for your Apple?
Time Machine on OS X is software
product that basically backs up
your computer every hour, and
then if something messes up,
you can restore your computer
to an earlier version.
It has a nice little interface
like with a little time
machine.
You can go back and look
at previous versions
of your computer.
GitHub is really similar.
It's very similar, except
it's tuned for working well
with source code, so it
has a lot of other features
that are useful for
software developers.
So if you're programming,
eventually you
will have to learn
Git at some point.
And GitHub is like
the most popular way
of using Git, that's
why people treat them
as almost the same thing.
So let's take a look.
The way GitHub
organizes things is
it has these things
called repositories.
And repository, you
could think of it
as like a folder or a project.
So every different project you'd
want to different repository.
So for this course website we
have one called mens-et-manus.
So where is that?
Ahh, here it is.
One of the things GitHub does
is it provides this fancy home
page for your projects, so
you can document your projects
on the homepage.
GitHub has a few ways
of interacting with it.
You can look at your files from
the web interface, GitHub.com.
There is also
text-based interfaces
and a visual interface
of GitHub Desktop, which
we'll use shortly.
A few things to note.
So this is the current,
latest version of your files.
This is a view of
the latest version.
Unlike Time Machine, it
doesn't automatically
create a new version every hour.
And if you used
Dropbox, Dropbox creates
a new version of your file
every time you change it.
GitHub does not
do that because it
wants you to explicitly say when
you've made a working change.
Because if you're changing
a piece of software,
you might change
three or four files
until you have a working next
version of your software.
So you basically
have to tell Git
every time you have a
new version that works.
And that's called the commit.
So the commits are
basically the history
of every time you've made a
change and told GitHub about it
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
I would like to know if
you made an account there
and put the files for the
course, uploaded them there.
ANDREW RINGLER: Yes.
Yes
AUDIENCE: And if we sign, we can
view this if we search for it.
Do we have to have access?
Do you have to give us access?
ANDREW RINGLER: I do, yes.
You'll notice a few things.
There's a little lock
icon and there's also
this text that says "private."
So yes, until I add
you, you will not
be able to see this URL.
AUDIENCE: Are you going to?
ANDREW RINGLER: Twist my arm.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: No, I wonder
if we are supposed
to use anything in there.
ANDREW RINGLER:
Yes, at some point
I will ask you all to
email me your GitHub user
names and [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
So the commits are
basically the history.
It's good to name them well.
So I said, "Link to electronic
books and schedule."
That's when I added this
schedule to the website.
"Added a group
project example"--
that was five hours ago.
So that's when I added this
example of group project.
So I basically made changes
and notated the change.
So you can view the whole
history of stuff on GitHub.
There's also a ton of other
features which we don't use.
You could submit bug
reports on their issues.
You can create a wiki
for your project,
which most people do not do.
All right.
The web interface--
you only really want
to use it as a
view of your files.
You don't actually
upload files there.
There is this Upload button
and Create a New File button,
but you don't want to use that.
What we actually do want
to use is this program
called GitHub Desktop.
GitHub Desktop is
similar to Dropbox.
Has anyone not heard of Dropbox?
Has anyone heard of Dropbox?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ANDREW RINGLER: Yes, it had
an IPO, it's a big company.
So Dropbox-- yes, here you go.
So Dropbox has a few things.
It has a sleek little program
that runs continuously.
And what it does is it takes
a folder on your hard disk.
And any file you
put in it, Dropbox
will upload it to the cloud.
And if you have Dropbox
on two computers,
it will automatically
sync them so you can
have two folders look the same.
GitHub Desktop is very similar
to that, except it does not
do anything automatically.
If you drop files in a
folder, it will detect them,
but it won't automatically
push them up to the cloud.
You have to do that manually.
The reason is--
what I said before--
is because you need
to really make sure
this is a change that
won't break the software,
so forcing developers
to write out the change,
helps make the software
easier to maintain.
OK, so in a moment--
I'll run through this quickly.
Let me tell you all the
steps that have to happen.
In a moment, on your own,
you will create an account
on GitHub.com.
It's a free account.
You can use any email
address you want.
You'll then download
GitHub Desktop--
that is also free software.
Once you've done that, you
can log into GitHub Desktop
and sync your cloud account with
this piece of software locally.
Once you log in,
you basically then
choose which repositories
you want to track.
And to do that, we hit the
Plus button, we say Clone.
Then we search for
the repository.
We clone it.
We choose a location to save it.
I'll run.
through this really
quickly and then
I'll step back for
everyone to do it.
So what it's doing,
a clone is basically
making a copy of the repository.
So there's a version in my
cloud at GitHub in California,
I guess.
So we're downloading that.
Once we downloaded it, we
could see a very similar view
to what we saw online.
Here "Link to electronic
books and schedule"--
that's same thing we
saw on the web page.
We'll say, "No
uncommitted changes."
Great.
As I mentioned, if you
drop a file in the folder--
GitHub Desktop has created
this folder for me, just
like a normal folder.
And these are all
the files in it.
So if we drag a new file into
it, just like with Dropbox--
let's drag up the final
version of an essay.
So I dragged it into
our repository folder
locally on my hard drive.
If we search back
to GitHub Desktop,
it's detected that change.
Then we want to commit.
So I said, "Added my
final essay version."
You always have to write
out a commit message.
It won't let you commit
without a message.
So I said, "Added
final version."
I'll say Commit.
That actually committed
locally on your computer.
So it creates the whole history.
Then we have to
do another step--
sync-- which syncs my
history on my laptop
with the universal history
on GitHub.com in California.
So once I hit Sync--
if we go back to the
web page and reload it,
we can see the essay is up here.
And we now have 566 commits.
The last one--
"Andrew Ringler
committed a minute ago,"
and my file essay version.
That's basically the idea of the
whole flow of files on GitHub.
Any questions so far?